need to all
um first of all i will do the
emergency evacuation announcement
should we be required to evacuate the
building would you please leave the
building by the double doors to the hall
go straight on then to the exit through
to the set of double doors
to the car park which is the assembly
point
please do not delay your evacuation
evacuation to collect any reliance
please do not return to the building
until given permission to do so by
council staff
please note that this meeting meeting
will be audio recorded
please switch off mobiles or turn them
on to silent
ready
members please be outstanding jersey
receives the chairman
chairman's chaplain and the chief
executive
[Music]
reverend nick ryan will
commence prayers
a line from a scripture from this
evening 1 peter 1 verse 13
therefore prepare your minds for action
discipline yourselves set all your hope
on the grace that jesus christ will
bring you when he is revealed
father god as we gather this evening our
minds may be filled with the increasing
troubles of this world around us
war in ukraine the plight of civilians
in war zones
and refugees seeking safety in foreign
lands
including this district
the cost of living crisis with rising
fuel bills and inflation
those suffering from poor
physical and mental health
we lift all affected by these troubles
to you asking for your peace your
provision
your comfort and healing to be at work
in each situation
we thank you for all counsellors who've
offered their time energy and intellect
to serve our local community
help them to prepare their minds for
action
to serve others and be part of the
solution
to the troubles of this world
by your grace reveal your will and be
their strength and their hope
almighty god from comes whom comes every
good and perfect gift we pray this
meeting will be conducted in a spirit of
justice of truth of wisdom and charity
we pray that mindful of their
responsibility and of the needs of those
they serve
each councillor and officer may use
their influence to promote the building
up of community and neighborhood
help them seek the way of love and peace
through him who is the prince of peace
our savior jesus christ
amen
please be seated members
i would just like to welcome all the
members including the newly elected
members
and say farewell and thank you to those
members who retired this year
and will also welcome officers and
members of the public in attendance
thank you nick for leading us in prayer
you are more than welcome to stay
and remain for the remainder of the
meeting however i know you have a busy
schedule and i understand that you may
need to leave us now
can i please take this opportunity to
thank you
for all your hard work and support over
the past year as chairman's chaplain it
has been greatly appreciated
thank you
[Applause]
welcome to rochford district council's
annual council meeting
can i please take this opportunity of
welcoming you
all on this municipal year
councillor belton
councillor cross councillor lamborn
councillor mason councillor sharp
councillor squires coleman and
councillor mrs wilson
i would like to welcome all re-elected
members and all other members council
officers and members of the public who
are joining us this evening
i would also like to say farewell to all
those councillors who are no longer
serving as councillors following this
year's elections
councillor dre councillor hazelwood
councillor merrick
councillor pavlin councillor shaw
councillor smith
and councillor weston
and i would like to thank them all for
their service to the council and to the
residents of rochford district
members when i invite you to speak
please ensure you have one of the
microphones in front of you before
speaking
as microphones are needed for the
hearing loop
and for the audio
these are all switched on ready for you
to speak so do not need to adjust them
please use the antibacterial wipes if
you do not if you do touch the
microphones
given the size of this room
and the numbers of us present when you
wish to speak or vote
can you please raise your hands clearly
high in the air
so that it can be easily seen by all and
leave it up until i ask you to lower it
agenda item 1
to elect the chairman of the council for
the 2022-23
municipal year
councillor wootton
thank you madam chairman uh it gives me
great pleasure to propose councillor
mike steptoe for that role
thank you
councillor
rowe
thank you chairman it gives me great
pleasure to second that thank you thank
you
i wonder
councillor wilkinson
thank you chair um forgive me if i take
a minute too longer than the the leader
did um i would like to propose
councillor lawman um for the role of
chairman of this council and for the
benefit of the new members here i'd just
like to say a couple of words about this
if i may
the chairman of the russian council is
an honour and it's an as a non-political
position traditionally it has been held
by
a member of the largest party and it's
usually the vice chairman of the
preceding year so it is traditional
that uh councillor steptoe would become
the new chairman
but it is a non-political position and
it can be anybody any member can be
elected to become a chairman of the
council councillor lawman has previously
been vice chairman of this council some
years back and has been through the
relevant training as well
he is very experienced of this sort of
thing as a very experienced counsellor
and it gives me great pleasure chairman
and members to nominate him please as an
alternative
thank you councillor wilkinson
what's the point of order i believe in
the in the elections chairman uh it's
not making speeches
really where's that laid down
i will now hand over to miss law to
present item one
thank you chairman two nominations have
been received for the chairman of the
council which has set out on the take
out in the table on page one of item one
the nominations will be determined by
voting chairman and this will be done by
roll call
members when sonia calls out your name
can you please say either name of the
councillor you wish to vote for either
council lawman or councillor steptoe
thank you
councillor mrs belton
councillor mrs butcher
councillor
councillor mr carter
counselor mrs carter
counselor constable
councillor steptoe
counselor crosstalk
um counselor fd council
counselor eves
mr gooding councillor steptoe
councillor mrs gooding
councillor hoy
councillor norman
councillor
knight
council lawman
cancer london
council lawman council lawman
council mrs lumley
councillor mrs mason
professor
myers
mr newport
abstain
council lisa newport council of lawmen
mrs shaw
how's the step toe
councillor wilkinson councillor lorman
councillor williams
councillor wilson epstein
councillor mrs wilson
councilman
and councillor
councillor steptoe
that was eleven
four
as he didn't actually vote
yeah and he wasn't asked to vote either
did you come on that group no crips
isn't on the list
okay
six abstentions and 21
for mike steptoe as chairman mike
steptoe you are now chairman
[Applause]
okay
on stepped home having been elected to
the office of chairman of the council of
the district of rochford
declare that i take the office upon
myself
and would duly and faithfully fulfill
the duties
of it accordingly
to the best of my judgment and ability
i undertake to observe the code of
conduct
which is expected of members of rochford
district council
members i'd like to thank you all for
your support
and as the declaration
states
i will do my best to make sure that
everybody has a fair hearing
uh members it gives me the great
pleasure
at this point
to
present
councillor gooding
a badge of a
previous channel
thanks julie thank you and julie do you
want to say this
[Applause]
okay
members are there any members that would
like to say a few words
at this point
council wouldn't
firstly mr chairman doesn't that sound
good firstly mr chairman councillor mike
slepto may i be the first to
congratulate you on being appointed the
chairman of rochford district council
i i know that we all wish you a
fantastic
new year new municipal year
and we wish you well
turning now
to
ex madam chairman councillor judy
gooding
i wish to take this opportunity to say a
few words
every mayor or chairman
taking office in the district or borough
council
puts their own stamp
on the role for that year
julie
you have certainly made a very positive
mark with passion
enthusiasm
commitment and dedication for all
aspects of the role
through covid
and unfortunate other circumstances
you were launched straight into the role
of chairman in may last year without
going through a preparatory year as vice
chairman
what a truly a great job
you have done as ambassador for the
rocha district this past year
in terms of community and business
despite covet restrictions in the early
part of the year
you have attended around 130
civic events and represented this
district
i'm sure there would have actually been
many more
had there been normality following on
from the pandemic
street naming attending the opening of
businesses helping to raise their
profile as well as providing
encouragement to entrepreneurs in the
district has been your mark
looking after residents interests across
the district
and as an example
working with me
in your capacity as chairman of the
trustees of the finchfield trust that's
just one example
i know your passion in terms of looking
after
residents in that case more elderly
residents of the district and your
enthusiasm to do the right by them
writing or personalizing many of your
speeches
i have been at a number of events with
you
when i thought well hasn't judy done
well
i recall the example of a road name in
street naming
on the edges of
rady hockley in bullwood hall
where prior to the event you had
personally been in touch with the family
to actually personalize and give some
empathy and identity
to that family
in the naming of the street
after squadron leader samuel bailey an
raf pilot tragically died who died in a
media collision in 2012.
other sad events
very sad tragic events through the year
have been the loss of our good friend
great canal
and the tragic murder of sir david amis
and other residents in the district you
have supported who passed away
there's also been the dreadful events in
ukraine
attending funerals memorial events with
huge dignity and respect
as our civic district representative
thank you
in terms of fundraising you named a
charity hackspace
who have worked out of the clements hall
pavilion you raise nearly 5 000 pounds
which in itself is a very creditable
feat
but you've also
raised for remap
and this is an organization that makes
equipment for people requiring it you've
raised a thousand pounds for them
but you were generous enough to
divert
your fundraising activities from
hackspace in your civic dinner
to events of ukraine
and in that respect you raised ten
thousand pounds just over ten thousand
pounds
with the assistance of some government
match funding
sixteen thousand pounds is a truly
wonderful
contribution in terms of your
fundraising role which is part of what
being the mayor or the chairman is all
about
judy a very sincere thank you
for all that you have done in your
special year
along with your husband councillor jim
gooding
you deserve
a good rest and we wish you well in the
future thank you very much
[Applause]
councillor mrs mason
thank you mr chairman and firstly and i
think most importantly i'd like to add
my congratulations to you
on becoming the chair for this year
and i will keep this very brief because
i think that's appropriate
but
i look forward to a period of
cooperation constructively working
together
and cohesive working for the future year
and i'm sure you will facilitate that
thank you
thank you
anybody else
counselor
it's a few words about retiring chairman
cancer judy gooding i've um
attended a few events this year which
she has organised i found it very
enjoyable very interesting and it was
good to talk to
members of other parties or
organizations at those events as well
and i'd just like to congratulate on the
amount of money she raised and
thank you
anybody else
members i'd just like to add my thanks
to julie
it has been a pleasure to be her deputy
she hasn't given me too much to do
because as you've already heard the
number of events that she
attended has been quite phenomenal
it has been a pleasure julie
and i
i don't know how you've managed to find
the time to do everything but i think
i'm going to find that out
but of course the other thing on top of
that your litter picks with jim
um i don't know how you found the time
to do it all right but congratulations
julie and thank you for a wonderful year
thank you thank you
council goody
chairman if you don't mind me just
for from my point i just it's been an
absolute honor and privilege
to represent rochford district council
on so many occasions during the past
year
i have reflected on these and
i did feel compelled to mention one of
one or two of those
events
which
counselor wootton has already mentioned
but
i cannot walk out of this this um
position without
mentioning
the devastation
of
the council meeting we held here where
we we lost a very dearly beloved
counsellor craig canel
his family and
loved ones and and all the counsellors
from all parties
i just want to acknowledge his
contribution
of service to raley town council to
rochford district council and to essex
county council
i would also like to thank councillor
mike stepto for supporting me throughout
the past year
in his role as vice chairman
of the council
reverend nick rowan for acting as
chairman's chaplain during the past year
leading us in prayer at council meetings
and presiding over
services such as the holocaust
memorial and hosting the civic service
at saint mary's church to name just a
couple of events which i know many of
you have attended
fellow councillors
mayors and chairmen from around the
county local mps and other dignitaries
who have supported me at my fundraising
and civic events i wish to thank you all
including those that attended the
charity dinners the race nights the quiz
nights etc and i really do appreciate
your support
the chauffeur colin basham
he does a fantastic job for supporting
me
during the very busy year and making
sure that i've always arrived on time
for all the civic engagements
as simon's already mentioned a
phenomenal amount of fundraising and i
would like to add that none of this
would have been possible without the
support of our members
it wouldn't have my sincerest thanks to
you all
i'd like to thank our senior officers
and the democratic services
for your support during the past year
and finally to my husband james for
accompanying me to many civic
engagements and to those councillors who
have stepped in on the occasion when
james was not available thank you
with that i will take my leave
thank you
[Applause]
members i'd just like to uh mention i
don't know if you spotted but i had some
very special guests with me here this
evening
my grandchildren came along
i can assure you i had no decision in
the blue dress that she was wearing
that was purely her choice so and
it was great to see him they've had to
sneak off because it's school day
tomorrow and i believe she's got some
tests so with this special dispensation
for mum and dad to come here this
evening but
i'd like to thank them for coming along
members uh we now move on to item three
which is in the capable hands of
miss law
thank you chairman two nominations have
been received in the office for the vice
chairman of the council and this is set
out on page one of item three
the nominations will be determined by
roll call
so members when sonia calls out your
name please can you say the name of the
counselor you wish to vote for either
councillor
lisa newport or councillor mcpherson
thank you
point of order chairman
shouldn't we know who the proposers and
seconders are at this stage
council
uh could i have the proposal for
uh councillor mrs
joe mcpherson
thank you mr chairman it gives me great
pleasure to propose councillor joe
mcpherson for the position of vice
chairman
councillor
thank you chairman it gives me great
pleasure to second that
and a proposal for councillor missy
newport
council mrs mason
thank you uh council steptoe i'd like to
propose
thank you
god
[Applause]
[Music]
crips
counsellor cross
council
councillor fd
councillor mcpherson
councillor mcpherson
councillor mr gooding
council of a person
counselor mrs gooding
councilman mcpherson
councillor hoy
councilor lisa newport
mr mason
councillor mrs newport thank you
councillor mrs mcpherson
councilman
councillor myers
councilman
councillor mr newport
council lisa newport council elisa
newport
cancer mrs rowe
councillor sharp council of newport
council mrs shaw
councillor sparring councilman person
counselor stanley
councillor
councillor steptoe
councillor mcpherson
council award
councillor webb
councillor wilkinson councillor mrs
mrs wilson
councillor lisa newport
councillor woodson councillors
members
that's 21 for councillor mrs mcpherson
and 17 for councillor this is newport
therefore declare
councilman mrs mcpherson
the new vice chair
councilman of fearsome would you like to
come and join me
[Applause]
okay okay
i jo and elizabeth mcpherson have been
elected to the office of vice chairman
of the council of the district of
rockford
i declare that i have taken the office
upon myself
and will duly and faithfully fulfill
the duties of it according to the best
of my judgment and ability
i understand to observe the code
of conduct which is expected of all
members of rochard district council
thank you members for your support
and i look forward to supporting
councillor steptoe in the full coming
year thank you
okay um
agenda item five
it gives me great pleasure
to announce
that
the the reverend kim lepley team rec
rector for the rochford parishes which
includes rochford barling and great
wakering has kindly agreed to serve as
chairman's chaplain for the municipal
war year
um obviously we'll be along
at the um coming along to do the um
beacon lightning on the second
of
june
at the mill hall
gender item six
apologies for absence
okay councillor mrs squires coleman
are there any others don't believe there
is
indication okay thank you
okay item agenda item seven
minutes of the meeting held on the 15th
of february
2022
and the 22nd of february 2022.
do members approve the minutes as a
correct record of the meeting can i have
a show of hands please
sorry council report did you want to say
something first
thank you chairman um
i wanted to um ask a question about the
minutes on page five item 36
and um
this is really for clarity and for newer
members as well so because a lot of this
sort of rolls on and you know it's
custom and practice so
basically um what we'd like to know what
i'd like to know is
when a council is no longer a councillor
and will they be representing the
council at the garden party
and
should the
um civic car and chauffeur be used to
transport the attendees still could you
just give us some clarity on that please
was nominated by council and voted on by
council um you know democratically um as
you know those nominations have to be
done well in advance
and
as a result he is the he is the
council's uh formal uh formal nominee to
attend that uh that garden party and it
has always been uh the case that the
the civic chauffeur and car has been
used for that purpose
nobody has this indicated
i have a show of hands that the minutes
are an accurate record of the meetings
i've given
okay keep your hand up while i just
count
um
okay lower hands
any against
any abstentions
okay the item is carried
okay
agenda gender item eight
announcements from the chair
and or the head of paid services
there is none from the chief executive
at this stage
i haven't got anything further i will
announce my charity at the next meeting
so everybody will know by the next
meeting
agenda item nine
district and parish council election
results
members you've all had a copy of that
are the are they noted
gender item 10
notice of group group memberships
members again you've already had a copy
of this
is that julie noted
gender item 11
appointment of the executive and
committees
uh
this law is to present this item
thank you chairman
chairman item 11 of the report sets out
the proposals for the discharge of
business for the
2022-23 municipal year
the recommendations are set out in
paragraph 12 of the report
the leaders appointed to the executive
have been set out on page 11.8
council
the recommendations are set out in
paragraph 12 of the report
uh being the leaders appointed
sorry
the leaders appointed to the executive
have been set out on page 11.8
and further to the review of the council
scrutiny function by the center of
governments and scrutiny there is a
recognition that scrutiny needs to be
more focused on strategic issues where
it can
influence and
have input into decision making process
at earlier stage
is just being handed out to uh members
if you just hang the second remove that
copy
cut sleeves
okay could we have a copy on the top
table please
thank you
okay
uh councillors you have a question
yes thank you
just for clarity um obviously the
portfolios have been renamed
on the climate and economy i presume
that is
business
an enterprise
sorry which one was that climate and
economy
does that cover business and enterprise
yes
thank you yes
councillor
we have a
website which shows
it eleven it doesn't show 11.8 if you go
into the website at this moment in time
will that be updated
after the after the meeting it does seem
wrong it's updated after the meeting
rather than before the meeting or at the
beginning of the meeting
yes it would be duly not updated after
the meeting
what's the run
it's not really a point of order but can
we allow our leader to speak and explain
setup please that's that was the idea
thank you
councilwood
thank you mr chairman i wasn't quite
sure where to come in there before we
actually start getting questions but
it gives me great pleasure uh to um
reappoint uh councilman mrs rowe as
the deputy leader
but he gives me even more pleasure to
welcome back to the executive team
council mrs danielle belton
and i can't think of a more fitting
title for her portfolio than climate and
economy
and um
it really represents and there were
comments made at a previous council
meeting
questioning the administration's
commitment to climate change and carbon
neutrality and the commitment for this
authority to be carbon neutral the
ambition that we set
several years ago now to be carbon
neutral by 2030
council and mrs belton you have a
challenge on your hands and i'm sure you
will do everything you can to rise to
that occasion
especially as
we have put money
at the last executive
to make sure that we put money where our
mouth is
communities and health
counselor arthur williams
environment councillor dave sparring
housing assets and leisure councillor
mike webb
customer services legal and i.t
councillor daniel fd
and strategic planning councillor ian
ward
apart from
modernizing some of our titles and doing
some better alignment
the detail of what sits behind those
portfolio holder roles will be
circulated in due course
and uh thank you very much indeed mr
chairman thank you council autumn can
you just confirm
uh councillor's question that uh council
and mrs belton will be looking after the
business aspect of things
absolutely happy to confirm that
okay
this is law
chairman um
i won't
uh
go through the whole report chairman all
i can say is that the recommendations
are set out
on page 11.4
at paragraph 12.
members you are asked to
note the appointment of the executive as
set out addendum 1
page 11.8
are they noted members
members following the review
of the operation of the scrutiny
sorry let me do that again members
following a review of the operation of
scrutiny at the council
by
center for governance
and scrutiny it's proposed that the name
of the review committee be changed
to overview and scrutiny committee
is that approved membership
okay
recommendation has been carried
recommendation three
next the political composition of the
council should be reflected
in the allocation of seats of the
council's committees appendix 1 to the
report
set out on pages 11.5
to 11.7
shows seats allocation based on the
current composition in accordance with
the pro rata rules
it also sets out the terms of reference
to all committees
council
is asked to
endorse
appendix one
members can i i'm sorry
yeah
yeah
members can i have a show of hands in
favour
okay
blow your hands members
those against
any abstentions
that is carried
recommendation four oh sorry counselor
stanley
requested earlier could you put that
microphone about two inches further to
your face so that i can hear you please
i'll use both so you should get me
should get me in stereo hopefully
okay
recommendation for
group leaders have been invited to
nominate council's
nominee to the council's committees
uh item 11
addendum 2
commencing on page 11.9
and running to page 11.11
sets out the memberships of the
committees
they would take in on on board the
nominations that have been received
can members please agree endorse the
nomination set out in addendum
oh sorry
yeah
yeah
set out an addendum 2 on pages 11.9 to
11.11
members those in favor
blow your hands members
any against
any abstentions
okay
members that has been carried
you want to do that
we just renamed the
committee to be
overview and scrutiny
apologies
yes we just renamed the committee
overview and scrutiny
but in the uh committee list it's still
got the word review in there
just to correct that
chairman at the time writing the report
it's it's still review committee up
until a few moments ago when it's been
changed to overview and scrutiny
for the next bit
chairman
nominations have been received from
group leaders for chairman and vice
chairman of the committees
these have been set out in addendum 3 at
page 11.12
and can be endorsed subject to dealing
with two nominations that have been
received for the vice chairman of the
development committee
two nominations for the chairman of
overview and scrutiny to end two
nominations for the chairman of
standards committee
the nominations for those those
committees will be determined by a role
corps
so turning to the vice chairman of
development committee can i just take a
question yeah uh councillor mrs mrs
mason
thank you mr chairman it's a small point
but we've just taken a a couple of um
votes and it would have been nice to
know how many votes were taken i think
in the order of transparency it would be
nice if once the vote is taken the
numbers are given thank you
the vote for
recommendation 3 was 31 votes for
no votes against and no abstentions for
recommendation 4 35 votes for
no abstentions and no votes against
members when sonia calls out your name
can you please say the name of the
council you wish to vote for
either councillor crips or councillor fd
cancer mrs butcher
cancer mr carter
counselor mrs carter
councillor eves
councillor foster
councillor fd
council mrs gadsden counselor
councillor mr gooding councillor
mr newport
councillor crips
councillor lisa newport councillor crips
counselor mrs rowe
now
councillor wilkinson councillor crips
councillor williams
councillor mr wilson councillor crips
council mrs wilson
councillor whatton
councillor
members
there was 16 for council recruits
and 22 for councillor empty
therefore council fd is
nominated as the vice chair of the plan
council
you wanted to say last question uh thank
you chairman um not so much of a
question um i know there's not enough
microphones that they're right in front
of people but with the auditorium's
quite large i could hardly hear a couple
of members so it must be difficult for
our officer and also just for the
hearing loop so if you can if there's
one near you just lean forward so we can
hear you thank you
thank you
moving on to the chairman for the
overview and scrutiny committee members
when sonia calls out your name again can
you
say the name of the council you wish to
vote for either councillor eves or
councillor
stuart wilson
mr carter
wilson
councillor crips
councillor cross
councillor fd
councillor wilson
councillor reeves
wilson hanson mrs gooding councillor
wilson
councillor hoye
councillor knight
councillor lamborn
councillor lawman
wilson
councillor mrs lumley
councillor mrs mason
uh councillor eve thank you
councillor mr mason councillor reeves
thank you
council mrs mcpherson
councillor milne
council wilson
councillor
myers councillor wilson
council mr newport
abstain
councillor lisa newport councillor ease
counsellor mrs rowe
councillor sharpe
councillor mrs shaw
councillor sparring counselor wilson
councillor stanley
councillor stepjo
council award councillor wilson
councillor webb
councillor wilkinson
councillor wilson
councillor williams
councillor mr wilson councillor wilson
council mrs wilson counselor
councillor
whitton wilson
24th
members
that's 24 for councillor wilson
nine for councillor eaves
and five absentians
i therefore declare that uh council
wilson is duly elected as chairman of
the ovu and scrutiny committee
thank you chair
turning to the chairman of the standards
committee members again when sonia calls
out call out your name please can you
say the name of the councillor you wish
to vote for
either councillor macpherson or
councillor stanley
counselor mrs belton
councillor mrs butcher councillor
mcpherson
councillor mr carter
councillor mrs carter
councillor
councillor constable
councillor mrs mcpherson
councillor crepes
councillor
macpherson
council mrs gadsden councillor mcpherson
councillor mr gooding
councillor mrs mcpherson
hanson mrs gooding councillor mrs
mcpherson
councillor hoy
councillor stanley
councillor knight
stanley
councillor lamborn
councillor lawmen
counselor mrs lumley
councillor mrs mason
helsler stanley thank you
counselor mr mason councillor stanley
thank you
councillor mrs mcpherson
councillor milne
councillor myers
councillor newport councillor stanley
councillor lisa newport councillor
stanley
councillor mrs rowe
councillor sharpe councillor
counselor mrs shaw
councillor sparring mcpherson
councillor stanley
council stanley
councillor stato
councillor
williams
counselors
okay members
there's three votes for councillor
mcpherson
14 votes for councillor stanley
and one abstention
i therefore declare that councillor
mcpherson
is chair of the standards committee
chairman can we
chairman can we please agree the
appointment of the chairman and vice
chairman of the committees as set out on
page 11.12 of addendum 3
subject to the
appointment of councillor fd as vice
chairman of development committee
councillor wilson as chairman of
overview and scrutiny committee and
councillor
uh macpherson
uh of the as chairman of the standards
committee
members
remembers i need to show hand sorry
could i have a show hands in favor
please
those
against any abstentions
okay members
that's 32
4
none against and one abstention
you chairman
finally chairman moving on to
recommendation six a nomination has been
received to appoint councillor butcher
as as the armed forces covenant champion
for 2022-23
this is set out in addendum 4 on page 11
13.
councillor you had your hand up
um
very pleased that leslie butcher has
that position um however going forward
i would like a review of that position
please because i know that there are
several councillors in this room that
would actually like to
take that position so perhaps
i don't know somebody working alongside
leslie going forward but i'd like to see
that reviewed please thank you chairman
members
those in favor of councillor leslie
butcher
to act as the services menu
mentor
please
those in favor
those
three handstand members
those against
any abstentions
members that's 34
not against and five abstentions
okay
that concludes that item
item 14
oh sorry
sorry members my uh
my paperwork seems to be ahead of itself
uh item 12
members do you agree the scheme of
delegation has set out in part three a
and c of the constitution
council mrs mason
thank you mr chairman i'm sorry if we
misheard you but i thought you said 34
and five abstentions
3-0 3-0 thank you
i just wondered how i got there no it
was
delicious thank you very much thanks for
the clarity
okay
okay
members just to
confirm here the scheme of delegation
members do you agree
that the scheme of delegation has set
out in part three a and c of the
constitution
those in favor
members can i make can you make sure
your hands are clearly up
like when you were at school
okay
lower your hands those against
any abstentions
oh
okay
members
that's 25 4
none against
and seven abstentions
okay thank you members
item 13.
do you want to do that
members
this item is to approve the scheduling
of the council meetings as set out in
agenda
as they're set out in the agenda
26th of july 2022
25th of october 2022
13th of december 2022
15th of february 2023
21st of february 2023
subject to the amending the date of the
extraordinary meeting on the 20th of
june
to the 14th of june 2022
members can i have a show hands of those
in favor
so
blow your hands members
those against
any abstentions
thank you members
members
that's 28 4
7 against
and two abstentions
members
agenda item 14
appointment to the representatives to
outside bodies and other forums
for the year 2022-2023
mrs law
chairman the members are invited to
appoint representatives
to serve on the outside bodies and other
forums for this municipal year
council is asked to make the decision on
the nine recommendations as set out on
page 14.4
council stanley
will the council have
the outside bodies report to the
council at council meetings
and will that be put on the web for
everyone to see thank you
stanley the report is in the members
bulletin
it would be reported in the members
bulletin
okay
thank you chairman
as stated the council is quiet to make
the decisions as set out on page 14.4 of
the report
the first recommendation is for the
appointment of officers and portfolio
holders to the outside bodies for the
2022-20 municipal year on the basis set
out on page 14.6
of appendix 1 to this report
and the appointees are listed in
addendum 1 on pages 14.9 and 14.10
that is to be agreed chairman
members those in favor
put your hands down members
those guys
any abstentions
members that's 24 for four
none against
and 11 extensions
that's carrie
thank you chairman moving on to
recommendation two
this is for uh the appointment of member
representatives including a number of
substitutes for the
2022-23 municipal year to the outside
bodies set out on pages 14.7
and 14.8 of appendix 2 to this report
the named bodies and the nominations
received to them are set out in addendum
2 to the report on pages 14.11 to 14.12.
that is to be agreed chairman subject to
dealing with
dealing with multiple nominations that
have been received for some of the
outside bodies
again chairman these will be dealt by
way of roll call
to take these in turn
just with the grange community
association
if we are appointing people to this body
i'm aware that it sets out what the role
and responsibilities are
but um
i'm a bit concerned that we have
appointed
people to this body over the last few
years
the accounts were filed about 360 odd
days late there's some accounts still
not done i do have concerns about this
body and whether or not it's being
monitored properly by our
representatives
i'm sure our representatives will take
that on board
once they are elected
chairman two nominations have been
received
uh for council sparing and council
stanley for one appointment
to the essex flood partnership board
members when sonia calls out your name
can you please say the name of the
council you wish to vote for either
councillor sparing or councillor stanley
council mr carter
please
councillor
councillor mrs gadsden
councillor mr gooding councillors ferry
councillor mrs gooding
councillor sparring councillor hoy
councillor stanley
councillor knight
and councillors
councillor lamborn
council
councillor lawman
counselor mrs lumley
councillor mrs mason
[Music]
stanley thank you councillor mr mason
councillor stanley
councillor mrs mcpherson
council milner
lisa newport council stanley
councillor mrs rowe
councillor sharp councillor
cancer mrs shaw
councillor
spuring chancellor stanley
councillor stanley
councillor
council award
councillor webb
councillor wilkinson
abstain
councillor williams
councillor mr wilson councillor stanley
councillor mrs wilson
councillor
council sparing
members
that's 20 for councillor sparring
16 for councillor
stanley
and two
abstentions therefore declare the
council of sparing is julia elected to
the post
chairman nominations have been received
for councillor
uh lumley councillor lisa newport
councillor sparring for two appointments
to the rayleigh grange community center
association
again members we will
conduct this vote by roll call sonia
will call out your name
um can you please state which two
councillors you wish to vote for either
council alumnly council lisa newport
or councillor sparing thank you
councillor mrs belton
councillor mrs butcher councillor this
is
mr carter
councillor mrs carter
um
and abstain
counsellor fd
councillors family and spirit
counselor reeves
[Music]
and sperry
councillor mr gooding
councillor mrs lumley and councillor
sperry
hansen mrs gooding councillor mrs lumley
and council sparring
councillor hoy
councillor
councillor knight
council elise
thank you
councillor
mrs lumley
thank you council mrs mcpherson
councilman
[Music]
councillor myers
lisa newport
mrs shaw
councillor sparing councillors
councillor stanley
councillor mrs newport and abstain
councillor webb
councillor williams
mrs welton
councillors
i know
23.
twenty-three
um
members
there's 23 for councillor lamley
17 for councillor leeson newport
and 21 for councillor sparing
therefore declare
the councillors lumley and sparing are
duly elected to the post
thank you chairman
moving on to the rayleigh mount local
committee
two nominations have been received for
one position
councillor cross and council emil
again we will conduct this by roll call
members when your name is called please
can you state whether you wish to vote
for council sparing or councillor
no sorry council cross or councilman
mill
councillor mrs belton
meal
counselor crips
counsellor cross council cross
councillor fd castle
councillor reeves
councillor foster
catherine mill
councilmancer
councilman
councillor mr gooding councillor meal
councillor mrs gooding councillor milne
councillor hoy
councillor cross
councillor knight
lacrosse
councillor london blunborn
councillor lawman cancer across
councillor mrs lundley
councillor mrs mason
hell's lacrosse thank you answer mr
mason council lacrosse councillor mrs
mcpherson
councillor milne
councillor myers
councillor mr
counselor newport newport council
councillor mrs rowe
councillor sharp council lacrosse
council mrs shaw
councillor
councillor
councillor stanley council lacrosse
council
council award
council of weber
[Music]
mrs wilson council across
council of watson
members
that's 17 for council lacrosse
and 20
21 for council emil
i therefore declare that council emil is
duly elected
chairman
following those um nominations being
concluded can the appointment set out in
addendum 2 on pages
14.
eleven
to fourteen point twelve subject to
noting the results of the votes we have
taken
uh be voted on
members
the appointments are set out in the
addendum 2
on pages 14.11
to 14.12
degrees subject to the votes that have
been taken
can those in favor please raise your
hands
keep them up while the officers count
so
blow your hand as members
those against
any abstentions
members that's 27 4
not against and six abstentions
there's therefore carriage
chairman moving on to recommendation
three
this relates to the attendance by the
leader of the council and portfolio
holders as the council representatives
at a number of external partnerships as
detailed in paragraph
3.4 of the report
this is to be noted by the council
chairman
members is that noted
thank you
recommendation for relates to the
appointment to three seats on the
sanctuary enrochable committee for
this municipal year
we have received sixth nomination
very briefly
which would include the withdrawal of my
nomination when i was first a member of
this council i think councillor
mcpherson nominated me for an outside
body as a substitute to her
um the late councillor cut more very
kindly
allowed me to be nominated to the
original sanctuary board for three years
um i'm withdrawing my nomination because
we don't seem to have that kind of
relationship anymore between the groups
and i find it quite sad so i'll be
withdrawing my nomination on that basis
thank you
thank you
chairman therefore we now have five
nominations for three appointments for
councillor eaves council alumni
councillor mill
councillor mr newport councillor
shaw as set out in the addendum on page
14.13
this will be again subject to a roll
call
members
when sonia calls out your name
can you please say the names of three
councillors you wish to vote for either
councillor eaves council alumni
councilman
councillor mr newport or council ashore
thank you
councillor mrs belton
councillor butcher
mr carter
councillor mrs carter
councillor eves
councillor foster
cancer lovely
counselor mrs gadsden counselor
counselor mr gooding
councillors mrs lumley councillor mill
and councillor mrs shaw
councillor mrs gooding
councillors
councillor hoy
councillor eves and councillor james
newport
counselor knight
[Music]
councillor lamborn
councillor
shawn
counselor lumley
counselor mrs mason
and newport
thank you
counselor mr mason
councilor sun council
mcpherson
councillor milner
mr newport
james
councillor lisa newport councillor eve
and councillor james newport
counselor mrs rowe
council
councilmember
shaw
councillor sharpe councillors
councillor mrs shaw
councillor sparing
councillors
councillor
stanley
council reeves and councillor dupont
councillors
webb
councillors
councillor williams
mr wilson
councillors and councillor newport
council mrs wilson
uh councillor eve and kenneth
thank you
councillor woodson
councilman
17.
17
okay members
that's 17 for councillor ease
24 for councillor mrs lumley
21 for councillor milne
17
for councilman
james newport
and 22 for councillor mrs shaw
okay
councillors lumley mill and shaw
are therefore elected to the sanctuary
that is carrying
thank you
recommendation
recommendation 5 relates to the
appointment to the essex police fire and
crime panel the nominations are set out
in addendum 4 on page 14.14
to be agreed by the council thank you
jim
members are the appointments
to the essex police and fire and crime
panel as set out in on page 14.4 agreed
those in favor
so
blow your hands members
those against
any abstentions
members
that is 24 4
not against and 11 abstentions
thank you chairman
recommendation six relates to the
appointment to the essex county wide
traveler unit the nominations are set
out in addendum 5 on page 14.15
to be agreed by the council chairman
members
we'll have to have another show hands
are the appointments the essex country
count country county-wide traveler unit
sat out in addendum 5 on page 14.15
agreed members those in favor
hmm
okay lower hands members
those against
any abstentions
members that is 24 for four
none against
and eleven abstentions
thank you chairman
recommendation seven relates to
nominations to four seats on
the local highways panel and these are
set out in addendum 6 on page
14.16 to be agreed by council
members the appointments to the local
highways panel
are set out in addendum 6 on page 14.16
by show of hands members those in favor
blow your hands members
those against
other hands members any abstentions
members that's 23 4
against four
and eight abstentions
members recommendation eight relates to
the appointment appointment of two
members and two substitutes to the river
crouch coastal community team steering
group
and the nominations are set out in
addendum 7 on page 14.17
to be agreed by council chairman
members again by show hands
as laid out the appointments to the
river crouch coastal community
team steering group set out addendum 7
on pages 14.17
those in favor
go your hands members
those against
our hands
any abstentions
members
that is 23 4
8 against
five abstentions that's carried
thank you chairman finally
recommendation nine relates to the
appointment of seven members to the
partnership panel
on a pro writer basis and the
nominations are set out in the addendum
in addendum 8 on page 14.18.
members again by show of hands
the appointments to the partnership
panel set out in addendum 8 on page
14.18
those in favor
members that is unanimous thank you
okay
thank you chairman thank you members and
that concludes that item of business
members um just before you go
uh our chief executive
stevenson would just like to say a few
words
thank you chairman um i just wanted to
make an
announcement tonight or uh congratulate
um angela hutchinson taking up a recent
appointment at um castle point they'll
be formally um hopefully agreed at their
agm at castle point tomorrow but wanted
to congratulate her put on formal record
uh new appointment she's not leaving yet
so there'll be plenty of time to say
goodbye but it's not a long goodbye
because she will be our neighbour in
castle point and she's not going very
far but i just thought i'd like to make
that announcement tonight and
congratulate her
[Applause]
angela i wish you all the best in your
new endeavors
um
and i'm sure we will be seeing you at
various events
21
20.
please be upstanding for the chairman
thank you